welcome back to everybody who is in the
u.s. celebrated Thanksgiving we were off
for the long holiday weekend and a very
very disturbing and eventful break in a
sense I mean the real world resembling
mr. robot I don't know if people are
watching that series resembling mr.
robot more than ever after this weekend
teargas shot into Mexico by Border
Patrol Russia ramming Ukrainian ships
Trump shutting down a border crossing
and dissonant Li defending Saudi Arabian
murderers effectively while saying that
he's most thankful for himself this year
and we're going to talk about all of it
a good place to start is that there is
now going to be yet another sort of test
of Donald Trump's loyalty to the United
States versus his loyalty to other
countries because Russia has hid and
seized some Ukrainian ships Donald Trump
recently failed one of these loyalty
tests I mean it's insane that this is
even a conversation that we're having
but Donald Trump recently sided with
Saudi Arabian killers called the Saudi
royal family over our own and turkeys
intelligence agencies in the killing of
Jamal khashoggi and here comes another
test because Russian forces have
captured two gunboats and a tug
belonging to the Ukrainian Navy after
ramming the tug there's video of the
Russian vessel ramming the Ukrainian one
will be playing the video while we
discuss what happened and the story is
that Russia initially claimed the
Russian ships illegally entered Russian
waters Ukraine says Russia simply tried
to intercept our ships which were
sailing through a particular area of the
Black Sea a particular Strait which we
will talk about ramming their tug
ultimately being blocked by their tanker
Ukraine says the boats were hit and
disabled that there were six injuries
Russia saying no there were really only
three injuries that we know about Russia
says yes we did use force but the force
was warranted Ukraine says now the four
wasn't warranted the law is on our side
because of a 2003 treaty which says that
the Kerch Strait that's the specific
area the the specific body of water in
question is a shared territorial water
so let's take it piece by piece number
one there is some legal ambiguity here
in terms of the aggression and the uses
of force but the decision to escalate
was Russia's decision the curt's Strait
is a shared Strait based on the current
treaties that are in place the unite the
European Union has already decided
Russia has to allow access to Ukraine to
that Strait brushes in the wrong for
blocking it NATO says Ukraine has
sovereignty and territorial integrity
they must have access to the Kerch
Strait so the international response has
been very clear and then as an American
political show we get to what's Trump
going to do what's Trump going to say is
Trump going to side with Putin's Russia
the most likely scenario in my mind is
that Trump will sort of play coy and try
to stay out of it saying this is really
their problem or maybe he'll issue like
a conditional criticism of Russian
action that's a common move that he does
Pat where he'll say well listen if XYZ
happened no matter who did it
whether it was Russia or anybody else
that's not a good thing and then he just
kind of like never mentions it again
that that's been his MO when it comes to
when he just can't defend the specific
actions of Putin he'll say I don't care
who does X nobody should be doing it and
then it's sort of like accepted as an
answer by many journalists sadly well
when asked about Russia's annexation of
Crimea back in 2014
Trump blames it on Obama so maybe we'll
see that happen again
I mean I guess Trump is lucky that there
were just injuries and no one was killed
here because then we'd have a situation
a lot more analogous to the khashoggi
situation I think he'll just kind of try
to stay out of it as much as he can well
there's a reasonable question that you
could hear Pat talk about what's Trump
going to do and hear me
about it and you might say David who
cares what the United States thinks who
hears what Donald Trump thinks about
this first of all come on that debt
that's sort of playing dumb right to
pretend that it doesn't matter how
Donald Trump responds to the military
aggression of a country we suspect he's
in cahoots with possibly in violation of
American law that's number one but
there's a second answer here and it's
more of a practical one Ukraine can't
retaliate in any serious way
they're just outgunned by Russia right
period and they would need foreign
support to do anything and to be taken
seriously and thus the International
reaction actually really matters this is
a major test it's a test for Trump it's
a test because Ukraine's future actually
does depend on whether NATO and the West
defend them against Russian aggression
and this once again is Russia's playbook
so discord in the United States create
situations where Donald Trump has to
choose sides or end up looking there's a
risk that Trump choosing the wrong side
and there's a risk to Trump sort of
staying out of it and increasingly being
not a player in geopolitics and and just
as a reminder Pat mentioned Khashoggi
Pat mentioned the annexation of Crimea
Russia also shot down a commercial
passenger plane and there have been the
most minor of consequences is Trump
really the law-and-order alpha who's
going to take care of business here's an
opportunity for him to do that and this
all is related to the circumstances also
connected to his reaction to the killing
of Jamaal khashoggi and that's what I
want to talk about next